we're a challenger brand so we knock on
the doors of CNN of MTV and we come
along we have a different viewpoint you
know we're a bit salty
you know least be called irreverent you
know I don't know we were called every
name in the book by every company in the
book but you know generally I believe
every media age has a changing of the
guard and right now it's Gen Y is the
changing of the guard and they have
their own language if we were to make a
pie chart and say you know what are the
different parts of the business and
where does your revenue come from how
would you define that well in the past
it was definitely working with brands to
create content for example with Intel we
partnered on the creators project which
has no other sponsors now it's happening
you know we always say premium online
content and what does that mean and
that's I guess why the HBO show was
important to us was because we wanted to
take online content to the gold standard
of TV and show that we could actually
make stuff that was of you know as good
if not better quality because for the
longest time online content was
synonymous with crap and then sort of TV
was last crap and then there's the holy
grail of films so we wanted to show that
we can do the gold standard now since
that's happened
we've been licensing a lot of our
content that we make online to
television Mobile in India television in
southeastern Europe you know basically
licensing all over the place which is a
sort of a pure margin business and then
you really make this big push with Vice
News which gives you a seat at the table
of you know the immediate things that
are happening more short form video
what's the cost that goes into that
we'll spend about 50 million dollars
over the next couple years
it started we just launched we're still
in beta we've only been up for two weeks
it's already been a tremendous success
with our coverage of the Crimea our
coverage of the riots in Venezuela our
dating news capsule you know not only is
it driving a lot of traffic for us but
it's also getting sort of kudos by
mainstream media who hitherto have been
doing nothing but making fun
would you have any interest in having
essentially your own cable network to
sort of be there for people to discover
you in that way well I would have said
no up until recently but we've been
selling so much TV around the world
whenever we look at something you know
we we were doing so many parties in
London so many events that we bought a
pub and and we put all our events in the
pub and that pub became our most wildly
successful adventure and we're selling
so much TV and creating so much IP now
that it's always smart to own your own
platform if you can so for us we are
looking at various opportunities because
there is such a Dee stratification going
on in media right now and we are
throwing off a lot of cash
that we can look at at buying distress
media assets and then seeing if we can
turn them around
you are a profitable company what does
that mean does it mean you're a wildly
profitable company I mean I would say
for what we do we're wildly profitable I
mean we've been profitable since day one
because we came up in a recession and we
believe you know you have to make profit
otherwise you don't exist well we've
been doubling our top-line pretty much
every year that we've been in existence
and which gets harder because there's a
lot more zeros in there now and our
margins have gone up as we as we are now
licensing to mobile online and TV around
the world as well as film our margins
are actually going up so we're running
at around a 34 percent margin we're
going to try to get to about 40 to 44
percent next year and then Oh Holy Grail
of 50 percent for an online company
would be would be it would be huge for
us what do you think your company is
worth a lot I don't know you know we
last year you know we got pegged at a
billion and a half and we've doubled
since then but we have a tremendous
scale growth that's going along with it
you know if if we hit our numbers this
year and project out the next year then
you know our worth would be you know
exponential I mean if we if we're doing
you know a billion dollars of top-line
at if
fifty percent are close to it margin
with the ever increasing scale that
would be worth as much as Twitter I
would think who you know are a great
company but not making any profit you're
close to generating a billion dollars in
revenue or that's the plan yeah within
next what 12 to 18 months 21st Century
Fox but a stake about 5% in any business
which got a lot of people talking about
what you're worth uh it was said that
you and Rupert Murdoch celebrated by
having a beer in Brooklyn is that what
no thank you for clarifying
hee-hee-hee what happened is we were
discussing some form of deal and we're
at his offices and he came in and and he
we talked for a bit and I said well you
should come see the shop and so he said
let's go now so he came out to Brooklyn
and we went to my favorite bar the hotel
del mono and we had a we had a drink and
then a lot of people saw us and he
tweeted and that started a whole rumor
and a lot of things but uh unrelated to
that the deal sort of you know took it a
life of its own and then later on we
ended up doing this deal at a around
five percent ownership sting I mean I
think a lot of people wonder about the
corporate end game here I mean you bet
ass before I mean I do want to sell this
business
I assume that you don't based on what
you've said in the past but I mean would
you consider something like going public
is that something that would interest
you well I think we have to look at
everything now it's it's a great
question one of the reasons why we did
the Fox deal people always say why did
you do a deal with Fox one of the
reasons why we did the deal with with
Fox was to stay independent and so
either we could run the business the way
we wanted to run I about 95 percent of
the board so you know it's a it's a it
was a great deal for us and it's been
it's it's helping us expand into the
world expanding to India expand into
Europe etc South America however that
said I think that you have to look at
things you know if we hit the numbers
that you know we we believe we're going
to hit we're throwing off so much money
our scale is increasing so rapidly we'd
be stupid not to test what the market
would bear there's a lot of money you
know sloshing around the system
obviously valuations are high God knows
when the next recession is coming and if
we didn't take some money off the table
we go out you know what about you
specifically as you know somebody who's
also getting out and doing a lot of the
storytelling which you've always done
you're doing a lot of you know a lot of
the the pieces that you might see online
that you might see on HBO to me it kind
of feels like a Martha Stewart factor
yeah you know as a Brit you know well
what do you think about that but you
know your name isn't on the brand per se
but you are definitely a big part of
this brand well I always say look if
you're gonna make cars you better love
making cars you know if you're going to
make grapple grommets you better love
making grandpa'll grommets we make
content so you know you better love
making content you better know every
aspect of making that content a B you
know I'm not gonna send anybody anywhere
that I'm not going to go myself also you
know I work for Vice you know I don't
work for CNN or fox or MSNBC or any of
the other so I can do what I want